[Music]
it's fun it's it's great when you get to
be involved in one of the films that's
being touted but it's it's just as much
fun to get to watch the films that are
sort of being out there even the ones
that don't necessarily get the same
traction it's wonderful to see the
diversity of films being included this
year we've got so many films in the
conversation and that are amazing I mean
we've got Black Panther we've got Mary
Poppins Returns it's like so cool Oscar
movie to me is that one that came out
and it really got you excited you want
to tell everyone you met to go to go see
it you want to have conversations about
it it was on the movie but it led you
down different roles and different
conversations and ideas that's Oscar
movies to me and and performances you'll
never forget it's all starts with a
script I think it has to have a terrific
direction and and really good
performances there's just there's a lot
of things to consider but the main thing
the film has to do was be good but I
read the script and was totally blown
away I'm you know the all three of these
characters are just any of these would
be a dream to play it's you it's usually
just something that works from beginning
to end and it's fills you up with
something good you know either it's
crushingly true and makes you it fills
you with belch merits for the suck for
the planet and for the population or
something vibrant and alive and just
makes you want to go out and wear the
masks my mom was my greatest supporter
till she died in 97
she'd be tickled about all this she'd
love this movie
I think I can't say enough that I think
mentors are the most important thing
that one could encounter along the way
people that care about you people that
help you on your journey
Bradley believed in me and you know I
really believed in him and I still do
all the time and I think that shows
itself in this film I think you know if
we didn't have that actual connection
and friendship you know behind the
scenes that it would be very different
but he he captured the honesty of our
you know private friendship as well as
you know the the love story and the
trust that they have with each other and
how much they believe in each other and
how that makes their love soar there's
something kind of cool about people
getting together and say hey let's
celebrate movies that are that are
really special and have something
something new to say yeah the remarkable
thing about it is whether like whether
you agree or disagree with the outcomes
you have national sometimes
international conversation about art
that lasts months that's like amazing
I would agree I think it I mean if if
there is some talk about a movie that
it's coming out that you're in like
Green Book and some people well you know
this could go all the way this could be
nominee for the screenplay and for this
and for that and whether that happens or
not it just means people like it for
some reason they like it for whatever
personal reason they're drawn to it they
think it has a chance to be light and
maybe seen more than once and stay in
people's memories so that's all good I
mean I have no idea to know you know how
it is define their who makes the
decision that a film is an Oscar movie I
never think about these things
before it actually happens I just tried
to do you know the best that I can with
the film and then if people appreciate
it and somehow it ends up being
characterized as an Oscar film or an
award worthy film or anything like that
it's always you know a huge positive for
the film this is the first time I've
been in that loop and so I'm honored
that they're even talking about the
movie in regard you know with you know
there's Oscar talk but what it means to
me is that people gonna hear about the
movie and that's what's important to me
I want people to see this movie I really
do I'd run much rather getting 0 Oscars
and make a ton of like everybody goes
and sees it it's not make money it's get
people to eyeballs on it it's not about
the thing I would just want people to
see because I do believe this movie can
make a little difference you know people
can it can bring people together it's
about people on both sides of the aisle
and how they gradually knock down the
walls and become friends and I I think
it's relevant today and that's why I
want people to see it
[Music]